foreign
[Music]
[Music]
together they create incredible
sculptures out of scrap metal
[Music]
this father-son duo got their start
making models of transformers
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the father and son went on to expand the
business beyond just transformers and
began building their own designs
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
my name is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
m complete
[Music]
[Music]
when a bag is made from a billboard it
has a story
it's creative it's bold
every bag is giving back and it's being
eco-friendly
[Music]
i was working advertising and i saw that
all the billboards that were going up in
essence were going to the landfill
most people don't know that billboards
are made of vinyl and it can be turned
into something else and so i thought
let's create a business that's
solely based on billboards
on any given month we get close to
around 10 000 pounds of billboards that
we turn into product
once that billboard goes up it's usually
up for a period of about four weeks is
what a typical campaign is on the street
for
[Music]
it's then shipped to our facility here
we sort it we cut it and send it to the
manufacturer where they do the final
sewing and cleaning of the product
we're able to take a billboard that had
one purpose and then reuse it to make
something else
my brother myself are both huge surfers
and we kind of felt like the surface
community loves bright colors and
billboard vinyl is actually very durable
it's a thick material it's waterproof
it's milder proof
so it's actually the perfect material
for a surfboard bag
after that we expand into backpacks
duffel bags wallets fanny packs hip
packs snowboard bags
every product is different every product
is one of a kind
each piece that we make
is unlike anything before it
our playground for all of us is based in
the environment whether it's
the mountains the rivers the the ocean
it's something that we in essence have a
responsibility to maintain and sustain
[Music]
i always thought you know a snowshoe
would really make a great cello a wooden
chair back
makes a cool guitar body it turns out
that one of my
most playable instruments is is a golf
club i'm seeing that transformative
quality in my head all the time
what can i say i'm attracted to trash i
don't know why
[Music]
check out the jimi hendrix of shovel
it's a guitar made up of lots of
junk he even plays his zipper from
brooklyn new york please welcome ken
butler
my name is ken butler
i'm an artist and musician and known for
building my own
experimental instruments
since 1978 i i think i've made around
400 instruments
this whole thing started for me when i
was in my basement in portland oregon
and i saw a rusty
old beat up hatchet
put two strings and two tuning pegs on
it plugged it into my guitar amp and was
quite stunned that it actually sounded
like a horrible violin
the axe violin was the first time that
somebody said that's a cool idea
[Music]
if i go walking around the neighborhood
everywhere you look you see such amazing
conglomerations of potential sculpture
there's crutches tennis rackets parts of
furniture boom i'm right there with that
you know when i build stringed
instruments
really just need three things
the head
the neck
and
the body
spoon
has that parameter a key
looks like a guitar as you know and then
there's the little body
this is from a
very inexpensive mandolin of course some
of the things become
crazy baroque assemblages of multiple
multiple necks it's ridiculous but
that's how it works
my shovel guitar i guess it's a small
snow shovel
it's just a quirky object and it sounds
unbelievably beautiful the qualities and
character that the golf club has is
amazing
there's one that's made from a beach
paddle that has a
ukulele neck and a cane
sometimes people think my intention is
humor it's not i think it's surprising
to people that i can generate genuine
emotion and meaning and real music on
something as ridiculous as
a hockey stick or a tennis racket or a
boom or a shovel or a golf club
at the real core of of what i'm doing
it's to communicate to other people that
the things right around them can be
magical and transformative and even
spiritual
who knows if if i hadn't found that ax
what would have happened
what you're seeing was built by one man
pebble by pebble
over 33 years
one morning mailman ferdinand chaval
stumbled across an interesting looking
stone on his delivery route
he picked it up
and from there an obsession began
using stones he collected on his walk
chaval worked each night without any
formal training to build what is now
called the palais ideal
the final structure is 85 feet long and
300 feet high
it mingles chinese algerian and northern
european influences to create a
fantastic and completely original castle
of grottoes
[Music]
he opened the palace in 1870 for the
public to enjoy
[Music]
in his own words he says
you start wondering if you have not been
carried away into a fantastic dream with
boundaries beyond the scope of
imagination
[Music]
and this incredible bizarre and unique
place
does look like something you could only
see in a dream
[Music]
you